welcome back everyone i'm rocket riley
and as you can probably tell from the
title i wanted to make a short video
explaining that my channel streaming the
galaxy will now just be called rocket
riley i've introduced myself as rocket
riley alongside the channel name in
every video but i've decided to change
the channel name itself the content
however should stay pretty much the same
throughout this branding change this is
a change i've been thinking about making
for a while now and i decided to go for
it for several reasons one of which is
that the search term streaming the
galaxy is highly valuable to companies
like samsung for their galaxy phones and
watches and for streaming services like
disney plus and netflix so they place a
lot of ads on these searches so if i
want my audience to be able to find my
channel more easily i'd need to change
the name of it also while i thought the
name streaming the galaxy was a creative
way to explain that the channel would be
covering topics about anything streaming
and more i think having a more personal
name associated with the channel will be
better in the long term really though
this channel name and branding change is
for you my audience without you and your
support i wouldn't be making these
videos and i truly appreciate all of you
it's crazy to think that just a few
months ago i had no subscribers and now
i have over 300 i hope all of you stick
with me as i continue making videos on
anything streaming and recent movie
releases especially if they have to do
with big fandoms like star wars and
marvel and that we can look back on this
video in the future and be shocked by
how small the channel used to be i look
forward to making more content for all
of you so if you have suggestions on
videos you'd like to see in the future
please drop your ideas in the comment
section below thanks for watching
rocketreily and i'll see you in the next
video